the uk's department for international
development works in deprived areas of
the world to make sure aid money reaches
people who need it now I don't have a
drama giving aid to people who are
suffering especially if we had a hand in
their misery however the decision to
give 98 million pounds worth of aid to a
country which has a nuclear program
space program and a thriving movie
industry is insane yes you heard me
right
India has all of the above not to
mention it now gives up more than 650
million pounds in aid that it receives
have we gone mad
we have an NHS on its knees spiralling
client all over frontline services
struggling to cope former servicemen are
homeless and injured and with funding
India whoever is sanctioning this lunacy
needs to have a long hard look at what
is going on around them what happened to
charity beginning at home I know some
amazing things I could do at night Nate
million and my list wouldn't include
lobbing another country's satellites up
in the air I'm now to start by saying
that there's no evidence that our money
is going to the space Bhagyam that's
what I've been asked to say so let's
make that clear I am I'm a great
believer in some in overseas aid I'm a
great supporter of it I have a problem
oddly when it comes to places like India
because India is increasingly a wealthy
nation and if India chooses that the
vast amount of that money should go to a
few rather than the many that's surely a
choice for India and I'm not sure that
we should be giving a dime in great
living giving aid to parts of ocean I'm
a great believer in giving aid to Africa
where I go in and do some stuff over
here but I do think there is an issue
about saying we'll hang on if this is
quite a rich country and it chooses that
that money should go to the few rather
than the many is that for us to
interfere and I'm not sure it is got
their own cash to do that with if they
want to do this we've got our own cash
and we need to spend on stuff that we
need to spend on as well as this many
times and I can see Greg looking at me
already but I distinctly agree with you
if a country we're either the fifth or
sixth richest in the planet if we can't
help
provide anti malaria nets for children
who are going to die that is a problem
is development where we then start
spending money on bridges in Uganda
wherever it might be or giving money as
you say to India which is country which
has its own foreign aid program so we as
you said now that so aid yes absolutely
we should development I have real
problems with and that's I've been over
to Africa and I've worked on quite a few
missions and I've seen owed money in
fact one job that I went on I was paid
in consecutively numbered hundred dollar
bills
that was eight money that had to be I'd
money nothing else okay so you know if
you'd have a hard enough job controlling
where that money goes all I'm saying is
we shouldn't be probably giving as much
as what we are and certainly shouldn't
be give more countries themselves India
is a sophisticated burgeoning economy
now it's something like seventh richest
economy in the world and it's it's
predicted this year it's gonna overtake
us and become the fifth richest economy
in the world and what I find incredible
is that in 2012 the Indian then Indian
finance minister told this country that
they didn't need or want our aid anymore
that they just didn't need it he
actually described at this Indian
Finance Minister as a pane of tin our
development as a peanut the indian
government were told by the british
government then to give up the safe to
cancel the aid would cause grave
political embarrassment this was a story
that was run of the telegraph back then
so we are giving money to an asian
superpower that doesn't actually want it
and this was in 2012 at a time this
country was in the grips of austerity
when we were closing libraries when the
NHS was in a mess with Social Care but
it was in the toilets so we were
throwing a hundred and fifty million
quid a year back then and we were
supposed to have given up giving aid to
India in 2015 why have we restarted
there richer than ever in in in the
Nexus predict about like 2025 their
economy would be five trillion I think
it's a my understanding that the
government is trying to sort of recast
aid as mutual economic development and
so that's why you have this odd
situation where by India is both a donor
and a recipient of aid
and it looks like countries are playing
this weird game of kind of beggar my
neighbor so I'll give you that and you
give me that and you sort of think why
are we doing this teresa may africa to
do it it's about mutual economic
development there actually were actually
investing and we're getting something
back with it we've got a clip of two e's
a man in africa that's what she said i
want to put our development budget and
expertise at the center of our
partnership as part of an ambitious new
approach and use this to support the
private sector to take root and grow and
I can today announce a new ambition by
2022
I want the UK to be the g7 s number-one
investor in Africa see I said as I said
this investments not handouts I I mean I
go to Uganda every year I give quite a
lot of money to certain projects there
and I think a lot of what he's done is
actually very effective but I think it's
the choice of the pop yes we elected
government the taxpayers money gone over
there you said the taxpayer where's your
quid go any go your weird piece a data
point as it's called now I heard
somebody and if it that one of the
problems with our aid budget what are
they now we now call our investment and
development budget or it's called is it
the disbursements parcels are can't be
smaller than five million so you have
these tiny charities or you know these
little projects and actually they don't
need five million you don't need to give
a woman's collective that's involved in
microfinance or whatever it is or using
energy from their mobile computer so
they gets five million do you see it a
little too clunky we keep all stops good
we keep on hearing stories don't worry
about how you know people in this
country are quite rightly furious about
it because they're giving their
hard-earned cash and the stories that
they hear a lot of the money goes to
cover up despots a lot of them money
goes on crazy schemes like
yes because don't forget there are two
sections part of the story is that
certain newspapers love to man and
therefore you believe that's all I go
I've seen a lot of the projects that are
there and some of them I think
incredibly effective do you think that
teaching kids in Tanzania had to juggle
is effective these organizations with
you know stack after stack of four by
fours paying extortionate rents to
people just taking the mickey basically
and I've seen in Afghanistan not seen in
Gaza I've seen all over the world is
nowhere I haven't been in that top list
of 20 or 10 to pick places where we give
the most of our rate up into all of them
apart from Somalia alright and all of
them wasting money somewhere
we're just hemorrhage money there is
some money wasted I think inevitably and
I I don't believe the figures and they
say what if you look at the figures they
come out if you'd they say only a tiny
percentage is waste I don't believe that
I think if you're gonna go and work in
this in certain countries you're bound
to lose some of the money which is what
is what the question is what is worth
doing and what isn't
let's hear what different Department of
international development actually say
DIF it ended traditional a to India in
2015 they tell us the UK now provides
the country with world leading expertise
and private investment which boost
prosperity create jobs and open up
markets while generating a return for
the UK at the same time this is firmly
in our interest not a penny of British
taxpayers aid money has gone on India's
space program supporting something you
said earlier great but just coming back
to mrs. may and African you've played in
that clip during that trip she pledged
four billion pounds and support referent
con amis in some instances a lot of it
to create jobs for young Africans
shouldn't she be creating jobs for young
bridge I want to come in on migration
you're off I often sit here and you say
why can't you know why do we have we've
got to stop non-eu migration if you're
gonna stop non-eu migration you have to
invest in what we can't call the third
world anyway we now call the global
South this is money well spent now what
about
I want you to accept my point that if
you want student the global noise and
find Georgia's here you need to help
them that and as Phil said at the start
of this charity begins at ur Mina this
money has been given away at a time when
when old people in this country are
dying because I think what matter the
projects I get involved in Africa I'm I
watch young people go from having no
hope to get some government money to as
well because we could do more but I mean
you should not underestimate poverty
exists these five billion bound loads as
five million you probably deal in I
don't know but tens of thousands so it's
carefully but it's not it's not pile
after pile of Land Rover and Mercedes
you're going to do is on the streets
here that's probably this poverty
probably all yes should we just should
be a few million quids the discussion we
were having at the beginning which is to
say how rich is a society how much is
that country and can that should that
deal with its own poverty India's I mean
unless I think is right yeah that's
right you for that thought ourselves out
before we start doling out around the
world